put yourself in the fan shoes for a
minute you've been waiting on one of
your favorite groups in the world to
drop an album for 10 years
now behind the scenes i've been taking
flights to new york go talk to paul
rosenberg i've been taking flights to
detroit talking to m talking to d uh to
rice how can we put this back together
you know what i mean and
it's it's not happened in 10 years
so it's like you know what
you're telling me you want me
to wait again and then i saw something
where roy said that we weren't waiting
on anybody that that's a lie
so i need to address all this stuff
because
whenever they say that i just come back
with the truth you know what i'm saying
like you you can attack my character my
integrity you could try to assassinate
it and say that i'm a liar and i'm doing
this for money and all this other type
of [ __ ] but i'ma just keep on hitting
back with truth we've we started off
slaughterhouse in the early days waiting
on joe
you know what i'm saying like when we
first got our deal with shady we had a
song called session one
on
on one of m's projects
he was trying to you know put the group
on one of his projects i think it was
gonna be a bonus cut or something on one
of the albums and you know we're new to
the label let me share my platform with
the group
so we do
session one
and all the slaughterhouse fans know
joe budden isn't on session one why
isn't jones session one
joe was signed
to another label he was caught up in
some paperwork was it e1 at the time or
something he was signed to amalgam
digital okay okay
okay
and
they
called over to shady like hey we have
him under contract you have to get a
clearance from us to have him appear on
that song
right
so we like wait a minute
because all of us
went in as supposedly free agents to
sign this deal with shady
and come to find out joe was on the
paperwork he said that they forged his
signature and that wasn't him
and
the group was put on the shelf for a
minute while he was
fighting amalgam digital in court
um and we were waiting on joe
because we couldn't move forward now
here we are with a brand new deal with
shady records
and we can't even really move forward as
a group because we gotta wait on joe in
court and that took months let me tell
you that took months right so after the
um
the signature expert determined that
that was his signature on the on the
contract
we was able to figure out how you know
after that you know what i mean and
um that was that was the first time
waiting on joe to give the fan
slaughterhouse
a lot of other
scenarios like that kept happening
you feel me so chill-related scenarios
joe related scenarios where we're
waiting on joe
okay so when when roy says we don't wait
on joe's like wait a minute what about
when we were
glass house was sitting around
collecting dust and we were all on a
conference call with paul rosenberg and
all of the shady staff and we said hey
guys when we gonna get back together to
do the album and we like okay let's
finish the album in the summer and joe's
like nah we can't do the summer
you know i gotta throw pool parties and
[ __ ] and i gotta do this other [ __ ] and
all that it's like okay so
we'll wait on that
um we'll we'll reconvene in september or
october hit him up september october no
i still ain't ready
waiting on joe so everybody was on the
same page to finish glass house except
joe for a while for a while
you know what i'm saying royce's studio
was always open see royce i feel he's
always down to work
if everybody is on board but if
everybody's not on board he's gonna do
his own thing which makes sense you feel
me yeah i mean that's that's just
logical um
it was always us waiting on joe to be on
board
and when i brought this last and final
opportunity to the table
and you telling me that i gotta wait on
joe
joe doesn't like it he wants to do some
other kind of deal well what kind of
deal does joe want to do because all of
a sudden
there's deals that he wants to do but
for 10 years there's been nothing it's
been crickets but now that i have this
now he wants to do another kind of deal
and it's like okay what kind of deal
does he want to do he wants to finance
it that's what i heard them talking
about when i did catch a piece of the
live they want to he wanted to finance
it he's like yo
it takes a lot of trust to go into that
type of business with somebody you know
i'm saying you got to
like
if i was to
if we would have to all for financing
one
it could never be just one person one
person and that one person could
definitely not be mr chopin i'm sorry
you know he don't have that type of
credit with me
when it comes to the business you know
what i'm saying now i'm just speaking on
slaughterhouse business he doesn't have
the credit with me
for me to say oh yeah cool you can find
answer joe um that's not gonna work so
um i don't know whatever kind of deal
that they envisioned for the group
it wasn't gonna work with me anyway so
we come to a stalemate i'm he don't
wanna do the deal i'm bringing and i'm
not doing the deal
his way so
it all leads to slaughterhouse being
over